so the Game of Thrones show is based off
a really long series of books longer
than the Lord of the Rings and the Bible
combined and the series hasn't even all
been written yet so to fit this huge
story into 73 hours of TV the show cuts
out a lot of characters and plots from
the books which kind of sucks because a
lot of them are really cool and
mysterious for example the story of Gary
and Lannister
the Lannisters we made in the show
include Tywin Father of cert Jaime and
Tyrion and Tywin's brother Kevin father
of Lancel Martin and Willem but in the
books Tywin has three more siblings
there's Jenna Lannister a smart
domineering woman married to a Frey and
ticket Lannister a skilled warrior who
died of EPOXI years ago and then there's
garyun garyun with Tyrion and Jamie's
favorite uncle growing up he taught
Tyrion to tumble to cartwheel and walk
on his hands and encouraged him to learn
about the wonders of the world this was
in contrast to the eldest lannister
Tywin always so Stern and serious ticket
and garyun felt they were in Thailand's
shadow but while kid got angry that he
could never match Tywin
garyun would make a joke of it all
better to mock the game than to play and
lose so garyun travelled the east he
competed in tournaments he fathered a
bastard daughter joy by a common woman
Briony and then about seven years before
the start of the main story
garyun went on a quest to find house
Lannisters lost Valyrian steel sword
bright raw so Valyrian steel is a
magical metal made in Valyria centuries
ago it was used to make weapons like
swords that were sharper stronger and
lighter than swords of regular steel but
when Valyria blew up in the doom the
secret of making the steel was lost now
there are only a couple of hundred
Valyrian steel blades left in Westeros
many of them are treasured as heirlooms
of noble houses for example heart's pain
is the Valyrian blade of house Tarly and
long claw with the sword of house
moments until you're gave it to Jon Snow
in the show John discovers Valyrian
steel can kill White Walkers which is
another reason it will be important
so bright role was once the Valyrian
blade of house lannister they paid a
huge amount of gold for us in the years
before the doom but a century later
after Valyria was destroyed King Tommen
Lannister went on an expedition to
plunder the ruins of Valyria he took
right roll with him and never returned
so bright row one of house Lannisters
most valuable treasures was lost and
ever since they've tried to replace it
Tywin offered to buy Valyrian swords
from poorer houses but was always
refused so garyun the more adventurous
or perhaps just reckless lannister
decided to go find bright Roy himself
where Tommen lofted centuries ago in the
ruins of Valyria
so Valyria was once the capital of a
prosperous powerful empire but after its
mysterious destruction of smoking broken
ruin remains in the show Tyrion and
Jorah sell through it like it ain't no
thang but in the books Valeria's cursed
it said the very caesar boils and smokes
the land is overrun with demons and
anyone who lays eyes upon its coast is
doomed whole armies have marched into
Valyria and never returned but that
didn't stop garyun he set sail from
Lannisport and headed for Valyria when
he stopped off at volantis half his crew
deserted him and he had to buy slaves to
replace them because everyone was so
scared of sailing the smoking sea after
volantis carrion disappeared and was
never seen again so what happened there
are lots of different theories the most
obvious one is that garyun died in
Valyria we don't know exactly what the
dangers of Valyria are whether the toxic
volcanic fumes or demons or magic but
it's clearly something nasty there
because it killed so many people before
gariands ancestor Tommen included garyun
might also have been shipwrecked
attacked by pirates or killed in a
mutiny of each crew however it happened
it's a likely explanation that garyun is
dead and won't be seen again but there
are other theories
not everyone who sailed the Valyria has
died euron greyjoy claims to have been
there and it looks like you're telling
the truth because in the books he has a
Valyrian dragon horn and a set of
Valyrian steel armor
if your on has been to Valyria and
garyun apparently died there maybe
you're on and garyun ran into each other
maybe you're on killed or captured
garyun
maybe garyun is one of the mute osmond
on yer on ship the silence but this is
unlikely because of the timelines
garyun failed to Valyria about eight
years ago but yer on went on his big
voyage about two years ago so unless
garyun was hanging around in Valyria for
six years he wouldn't have met you on
there another theory is that garyun
became the corsair king pirate who's
been mentioned raiding around the Summer
Isles but again the timeline doesn't fit
the corsair king is new only recently
started raiding so if the Corsair is
garyun what would be doing these last
eight years one of the crazier theories
is that garyun is the shrouded lord a
mysterious mystical figure who lives in
the sorrows which tyrion buzzes through
in dance youtuber press and jacobs
argues that the lord seems to spare
tyrion from getting greyscale from stone
men that both garyun and the shrouded
lord are associated with laughter and
that the Lord must look like garyun
because tyrion dreams of the Lord being
Tywin it's a fun idea but the text
doesn't really support it the dream has
nothing to do with garyun the laughter
connection is barely mentioned in the
text and the Lord sparing Tyrion is
tenuous at best to complicate things
some more it is mentioned that this
corsair king supposedly is the current
shrouded lord so it's most assuredly
confusing and complex but in the end
there's just no strong evidence that
garyun is the shrouded Lord or the
corsair king or anybody else not every
missing character has a twist and a
secret identity garyun probably is just
dead in Valyria but there's still
another theory to address it's about a
woman called the sailor's wife a
prostitute in Braavos who only beds the
men who marry her in fun little
temporary wedding ceremonies the
sailor's wife has a daughter called lana
who has fine long golden hair blonde
hair and the name lana makes a girl
sound like a Lannister right and we hear
that the sailors wife prays for her
first husband to a true husband her old
love who had been lost at sea maybe the
sailors left first husband and the
father of a blonde daughter Lana is Gary
and Lannister garyun was lost at sea
that's the exact phrase consistently
used to describe him and garyun would
explain Lana's blond hair and name
further the fortune-teller yena claims
that the sailor's wife's husband is dead
which fits the idea that Garrigan died
in Valyria so this seems like a pretty
strong theory but again
the timings tricky Lana is 14 in the
fourth book which means she was fathered
years before Gary and failed to find
bright roar which is fine because we
know he travelled the east before but
remember Gary and daughter joy she is 11
in the fourth book which means for Gary
in to have fathered both joy and Lana
he must have sailed to Braavos married
the sailors wife and fathered Lana then
left and just two years later fathered
joy on Briony in Westeros and a few
years after that failed to Valyria and
died which is possible but seems weird
it totally undercuts the whole tragic
love story of the sailor's wife if her
long-lost husband actually just dumped
her and left to hook up with someone
else also the sailors wife was no older
than 14 when her husband left and she
and a child both work as prostitutes to
support themselves
why would garyun not just send a little
Lannister gold their way at some point
joy seems to be pretty well supported
why treat the sailor's wife differently
Tyrion favorite uncle doesn't sound like
the sort of guy to so coldly abandon a
loving wife and child so what gives
there might be a solution in the timing
while writing a fourth game of Thrones
book George Martin plans to leave a
five-year gap between the third and
fourth books meaning book 4 would pick
up the story five years after the third
with all the characters five years older
Eyre would have spent five years
training with the faceless men and bran
would have been learning from bloodraven
but Martin found the gap didn't work so
well for other characters so after a
year of right
with cigar piece crafted and instead her
book for just pick up where book three
ended this man he had to go back and
rewrite a lot of what he's already
written changing stuff to remove the gap
he would have had to change details like
dates and years and ages the five-year
gap made everyone 5 years older so to go
back and remove the gap from what he'd
already written he would have had to
make some characters five years younger
maybe just maybe he made a mistake and
forgot to change back the age of Lana
because if Lana was five years younger
she'd be nine instead of 14 which would
mean she could have been conceived the
same year that garyun sailed for Valyria
which changes everything
instead of garyun having to sailed to
Braavos Mary then dumped the wife go
back to Westeros father joy then sailed
to Valyria he could have just stopped
off in brothels and met the wife along
the way to Valyria with every intention
of coming back to her until he was
tragically lost at sea leaving the wife
and Lana
longing never knowing if he'd return
that fits the tragic story of the
sailors wife so much better and the math
just works perfectly
Lana's 14 in feast - five - the gap
makes nine so should be born in the year
- nine one garyun sailed eight years
before storm which happens in two nine
nine so he sailed in about two nine one
it looks very very possible that George
Martin made a small mistake with Lana's
age so garyun probably didn't mean Iran
he probably isn't a Corsair or the
shrouded Lord he's probably a corpse
somewhere in Valyria which is just all
the more tragic because it looks like he
left behind a child and a wife who loves
him who he may have meant to return to
until he sadly died and you almost
wouldn't know it because it maybe George
forgot to do some math thanks for
watching some of these images come from
the world of Ice and Fire which you can
buy at the link below
this garyun art is by katherine on
deviantART and the Euron art is by
Yvonne Wallington you can find him on
Twitter thanks to the patrons for making
this video possible including
William Horner a controller Richard Ober
Scott Jennings and Persephone Jones
Cheers
you